Welcome.
In the last lecture we looked at point processes of an image that allowed us to
do simple arithmetic, addition,
subtraction of pixels from one image to the other.
Let's now look at the whole concept on how we can take a pixel and
look around the neighbor of that pixel and
use that information to improve the quality of an image.
For example, by looking at and averaging around a pixel, we can blur an image.
We can also do other things like, if there is noise in the image,
we can look at the neighborhood and again, get rid of the noise in an image.
So those kinds of processes let us now look at
neighborhoods of pixels within the single image of multiple images, and
use that to enhance the quality of images.
That's the kind of stuff we're going to look at in this series of lectures.